Emergency Services on the scene of a
suspected gas explosion southwest police
in the Welsh Ambulance Service were
called at just after 20 past 11 this
morning following a report of an
explosion in Morrison the latest we have
from the local police is that three
people have been taken to hospital one
person still unaccounted for joining us
now labor counselor for Morrison Rob
Stewart who has been at the scene today
and Mr Stewart thank you so much for
coming here on Sky News to provide us
with some form of update and can you
tell us about what you know happened
this morning we're seeing pictures here
coming into Sky News a scene of
Devastation we're not just talking
extensive damage we're talking about a
house that looks like it's been
completely flattened
yeah so yeah I've just returned from uh
visiting the the residents uh who are
being uh housed in a nearby Center
whilst uh investigations are underway
but as you quite rightly say a huge
explosion which occurred at around 20
past 11 this morning demolished one
house and as significantly damaged a
second and then provided damage to a
number of houses in the locality so
around 100 people 100 residents
displaced at the moment our teams are on
site with Emergency Services uh trying
to ensure that we account for everybody
and and that's what we're attempting to
do at the moment
um and obviously make sure that everyone
is safe
um but it is a significant incident and
as the pictures are showing it's uh it's
a scene of Devastation there so you can
you can smell gas in the air uh and uh
you know I was speaking to two uh
workmen who had been working about two
miles away and they thought the
explosion was was much closer to where
they were working but that just shows
how significant a blast this was yeah
it's incredible isn't it that more
properties weren't damaged just to
reiterate what the police have told us
is that three people have been taken to
hospital as a result of this they are
still searching for one other person
obviously you've been there to provide
support to the community we can see from
the pictures there people on the street
a real sense of shock that this has
happened on their doorstep and concern
as well was the area evacuated because
of course when something like this
happens you do have to sort of put a
cordon around it and protect the area
has there been an evacuation is there
somewhere for for local residents to go
yeah our teams have set up a community
center is open for people nearby we had
originally looked at a local football
club but because of the nature of the
blast it's also severed the electricity
connections to the properties nearby
um so we've we've set up a community
center where people are being supported
at the moment uh and uh as I said about
100 people displaced uh roads to that
area are now closed and there is a
cordon around the area so my officers in
Swansea comes on the leader of Swansea
Council as well as a local member are on
site there and uh I've also got family
and friends in that street so being to
visit them as well in the last hour or
so and you know it's it's brilliant
they're all pulling together supporting
one another but um you know we hope that
we can account for everybody uh very
soon and that uh hopefully nobody has uh
lost Life as a result of the explosion
but we won't know that for some time
yeah I mean everybody's Thoughts with
those effects because you know these
pictures are utterly shocking you know
there's a house destroyed as you said
they're still searching uh for one
person still missing police have advised
people to avoid the area the emergency
services are on the scene and the
utilities company as well how long
before people are allowed back do you
think how long is this this operation
going to be going on for
yeah that was the question everybody was
asking uh this afternoon when I was
there
um we just don't know unfortunately it's
going to take a while for the uh
emergency services to make sure that the
houses and that the area is safe uh once
that is the case then obviously we we
want to get people back into their homes
as soon as possible but we can't give a
uh time frame on that at the moment but
should they not be able to return to the
houses this evening obviously we're
trying to put in place other ways to
support uh residents until they can
return uh Rob Stewart labor counselor
for the Morrison wall we really
appreciate you coming on here to Sky
News to update us on what's unfolding uh
in your area